the DVD was a huge part of our business
of our Revenue stream and technology has
just made that Obsolete and so the
movies that that we used to make you
could afford to not make all of your
money when it played in the theater
because you knew you had the DVD coming
behind the release and six months later
you'd get all you know a whole nother
chunk it would be like reopening the
movie almost and when that went away
that changed the type of movies that we
could make and so now I'm in 50 million
dollars I have to split everything I get
with the exhibitor right the people who
own the movie theaters so I would have
to make a hundred million dollars before
I got into profit and and the idea of
making 100 million dollars on a story
about like this love affair between
these two people yeah I love everyone in
the movie but that's a that's suddenly a
massive gamble in a way that it wasn't
in the 1990s when they were making all
those kind of movies the kind of movies
that I loved and and the kind of movies
that were my bread and butter